is co-chairing that meeting this morning
so it's a joint meeting of Dua and liebe
we have also invited our fed colleagues
development colleagues say their
colleagues so that we have a broad
spectrum of uh
political responsibilities in this room
but also online it's my pleasure to
welcome folkat Turk this morning and
colleagues
we have the honor to welcome
the United Nations High Commissioner for
human rights
it's crucial
to have an open exchange with him
we congratulate him for his excellent
work and
for his start in this position
which he
started last year
but on the other hand
it's critical enough to have this
Exchange
because colleagues you know yourself are
critical the situation of human rights
in this world is and became we know that
more than
one in four children in poor countries
is involved in child labor
we know that more than 100 million
people on the globe are forcibly
displaced
and have to
look for new
uh places your new homes for new bases
to feed their family
we have the situation worsening for
civic Society organizations we speak of
shrinking spaces
and we see the attack on the Free Press
on journalists
go so far that modern 50 journalists
recently were killed the world needs
journalists more than ever
but it comes not by accident that
exactly
this profession is in the focus of the
autocrats
this is not the only problem that we
have to deal with
because
besides the real politics development
we also see that
The Narrative is under attack The
Narrative of human rights as a
indivisible as a universal concept
and this in the year where we would like
to celebrate which will be due in
November here with a high level
conference the 75th anniversary of the
Declaration
of Human Rights so there is issues
enough
to have a critical conversation on the
subject
the comedies involved
concentrate on the defense of Human
Rights
and permanently try to live up to the
obligation of the European Union which
is clearly documented in article 21 of
the Treaty of the European Union where
the European Union is obliged not only
to defend human rights but also support
human rights with all their actions in
all their negotiations in all their
policy fields in all the treaties
that we also agree with third countries
so now let me give this law to anjay for
his introductory remarks and then we are
looking forward to the exchange with
what I took
thank you very shortly I would like to
welcome you in Libya the committee name
liba means the committee for the focus
on civil liberties human rights Justice
and common affairs
um it's very important that we have this
common meeting together because Bob's
committees draw and labor are very
focused on human rights protection also
Within
European Union cameras but also outside
we are facing many challenges with
migration with Asylum policy you know
very well have important this also in
these days I have one additional
technical remark for our colleagues we
have translation in 12 languages German
English French Italian Dutch Greek
Spanish Portuguese Swedish Hungarian
polish and Romanian I hope it will be
enough for everybody and useful
also uh well let's
start the meeting because it's very
important we have limited time for the
meeting very happy to see a high
commission with us Volker took the first
time but not the last time I hope uh
let's not to prolong because the summer
holidays are coming so everybody is
thinking about the place
thank you
thank you Andre the floor is to polka
Turk I welcome also Christina kokinakis
here on the podium for the external
Action Service who will also address us
right after the introductory remarks of
folkata please you have this one
first of all it's an honor to be back in
Brussels it's actually my I have had a
couple of meetings with parliamentary
committees in my previous Incarnation
when I worked for unhcr but it's great
to be able to do it and to have an
exchange of you with yourselves
um as in my new function as high
Commission of Human Rights and it's it's
it's actually when you come through this
as fast Leopold there's one thing that
always strikes me
um it's this sense of
the institutions that we represent
well they didn't really exist
a lie a human lifetime ago and it
actually shows how important it is that
this common sense of values that they
represent the United Nations and the
European Union
actually underpins everything that we do
and I think it's important to sometimes
remember it especially when we have
these anniversaries and both
institutions were built as an act of
courage and Defiance in the face upon
War upon War upon War about atrocity
crimes Channelside and generations also
of exploitation and pain
and the United Nations as well as the
European Union were really built as an
act of Hope and a commitment to profound
and enduring principles
and the act that manifested themselves
the act that manifested the values that
75 years ago our forebears set out
to Mark A New Path to peace Justice
shared prosperity for all human beings
is best encapsulated in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights in 1948
because the draft is at the time when
they adopted the universal Declaration
of Human Rights they didn't think that
there was time for idle or idealism
they really forged these commitments as
practical solutions to the problems that
the world faced coming out of the second
world war and we know that these tools
have worked let's not forget this
we have seen over the past 75 years and
it's important to be aware of the
achievements that the World Europe have
made great strides away from Colonial
exploitation from discrimination of
every kind and many other types of
injustices so nobody could claim
that this progress has been perfect
nobody is perfect but it is clear
that much of it of the progress that we
have achieved has been Guided by the
universal Declaration of Human Rights
and all the subsequent human rights
treaties that we have seen over the last
couple of decades and let's also not
forget the the universal Declaration of
Human Rights is the most translated
document on Earth
some would think it's different texts
but it's actually the universal
exploration of human rights as a result
we are in the Guinness Book of Records
as we approach this anniversary the this
year
we are also approaching
sorry
we are approaching a kind of Crossroads
we have seen this conjunction of
multiple crises that we have that you
we're all dealing with and the immense
significance that it has
so our choice is to act or not to act
with careful determination and in line
with these deep seated values and shared
values will alter many aspects of
politics of economy and Society across
Europe and the world
we have seen how Europe continues to
lead the development of careful
regulation on digital Technologies
especially in light of the intense
acceleration that we see with generative
Ai and so forth
we also know
how these in some instances have
unfortunately led to Echo Chambers and
extremist movements
especially when it comes to social media
platforms
and we also see the challenges that they
mean to privacy truth equality free
speech and but also Democratic
institutions so it's clear that we will
have to deal with them and Europe has
led the way in many respects but we also
know that the digital Technologies are
absolutely important especially in the
green transition uh to ensure that we
find the type of tools that we need in
order to to be able to confront these
challenges Russia's war on Ukraine
continues to threaten the world's peace
architecture right have to say that it
talks multilateral and Regional
institutions back to blocks and to
hostile standoffs just at a time when we
need to forge consensus solutions for
problems that are too big for any
country or for any region to face the
loan we also know climate change is out
of control
it's a triple planetary crisis is
threatening all of humanity there are
human rights implications in each and
every aspect of that
and I want to really acknowledge the
efforts of the European Union on on the
green transition and on climate change
more broadly but we also know that a lot
of more work needs to be done to stop
the subsidizing of the fossil fuel
industry before they turn all human
beings into fossils so that's a very
very important call to make
unfortunately we have also seen more
conflicts breaking out I mean the last
one is Sudan
we also see how there is this
interrelationship between environmental
degradation climate change fueling of
conflicts competition over scarce
resources and in fact Sudan demonstrates
how fragile peace is and how quickly
hard one gains can be lost
next we'll next next week I will go to
chart to give you an example where as
you have seen already over 100 refugees
from Sudan especially from from Darfur
have arrived and they already suffer
from the massive climate change impacts
and violent extremism that we see
you have just come back from New York on
the sustainable development agenda
we know how derailed that agenda has
been not least because of covet but also
because of many other reasons because
also of the sharp economic and social
inequalities that we see around the
world including with different parts
um if different middle-income countries
but low-income countries in particular
they have I mean if you look at some of
the statistics world food program
estimates that more than 345 million
people will face high levels of food
insecurity this year
more than double the number that we had
in 2020
and of course the conflict I mean the
war against Ukraine the climate change
are really some of the major drivers
behind
drug Global hunger the movement of
migrants and refugees is clearly related
to this dismal State of Affairs when it
comes especially to conflict economic
inequalities and social inequalities and
so forth but it has to be said most
displacement occurs within countries
we're talking here about internally
displaced people mostly in the poorest
regions of the world and I re I welcome
very much the fact that the European
Union member states have received over 4
million Ukrainian refugees
but I've also watched with great concern
how polarized and fraught with emotion
the debate has become also in Europe
about migration and Refugee protection
in Europe because it deepens
unfortunately some of the political
divisions that we see it also fuels
sometimes populist hostility rather than
what I think is necessary a much needed
evidence-based fact-based rational
debate that that actually helps us find
find Solutions
this I mean when in my previous position
I dealt a lot with the so-called
previous Australia models
Australia of deterring arrivals and
transferring people who are seeking
safety to third countries
of course this has raged huge human
rights concerns
it has actually also been a great cost
to taxpayers I mean if you look at it
from from that perspective as well and
we also see it's not viable
because what we need is actually
functioning Asylum systems and robust
immigration especially when we see that
birth rates are declining
we have seen in many countries around
the world on another issue including in
sometimes also in the EU
some backsliding on some key
fundamentally human rights commitments
it's important to support as much as
possible the widest possible Civic space
innovation
and creativity to be able to deal with
the big challenges of our times
are not coming with repression of Civic
space they will only work if you allow
Innovation and creativity to take place
it's also about upholding the principles
of equality and non-discrimination and
we have seen unfortunately a backlash
against women's rights reproductive
health and rights the rights of LGBT
LGBT IQ plus people and we really need
to make sure that there is a much
stronger work also Against Racism and to
uphold the work and the quality of
people of African descent and migrants
we have and I'm very much confronted
with it on a daily basis frankly some of
the political geopolitical tensions but
also the geo-economic
backdrop to human rights has been
quite something over the last couple of
years but we also know that human rights
is the compass that navigates us through
troubled times
and it's true that the universal
Declaration was precisely intended at a
time when the world was in turmoil and
in chaos to provide a guide forward
uh in order to find solutions to the
problems that we all face
human rights begin at home
they are not an Annex to foreign policy
or to geopolitics of any kind and Annex
at all they must be at the core of
legislation at the national and the EU
level and I'm glad that there are these
two committees that that meet together
on this because it is really also about
that
and we also know and that's a particular
point that I want to emphasize when it
comes to Human Rights economy we have
launched this concept of a human rights
economy because we need to look at
economic and fiscal policies from the
perspective and regulation of businesses
from the perspective of Human Rights and
you are demonstrating this with the
human rights safeguards especially in
Supply chains
and we need to make sure that at the
core of all decisions at the core of all
behaviors
made by public servants in every country
including teachers police forces and
coast guards that indeed there is an
awareness and the mindfulness of the
human rights of the human rights
Dimension as members of key committees
of the world's largest democratically
elected Parliament you are human rights
actors there's no doubt about this and I
encourage you especially in this
anniversary year
to make one or several pledges to take
action that can catalyze positive change
and transformative change in human
rights as we look to the Future
we have a big high-level event coming up
in Geneva on the
11th and 12th December and we can share
information with you about this but we
hope that we can develop a fledging tree
to actually look to the future with the
type of things that we can all commit to
on the human rights front so that
human rights is not becoming the
collateral damage of geopolitics so
very much thank you for all the work
that you have been doing all the support
that we get from you as a donor as a
political as a strategic partner and you
know hopefully we can work together on
many fronts and I would like to thank
you in particular as parliamentarians
for being such steadfast supporters of
my office and of the human rights course
at the global level thank you
thank you so much I commissioned uh
Christina if it's okay for you we go
around the colleagues on the floor Angie
myself will will invite them to take the
floor and you come in and have also the
capacity then to comment directly also
to what colleagues have said uh because
uh Focus was mentioning inequalities and
the performance of the European Union
let me only depart back from the
high-level political Forum in New York
where the first review of a European
Union achievements on the sdgs was
presented by commissioner gentilloni as
well as by commissioner opeline and Utah
Opera and took the floor especially on
the external dimension of our activities
and she put uh
on the highest point of her agenda to
fight against inequalities also
introducing the new methodology of
inequality marker that she had already
presented in Paris in the conference in
Paris recently where we as European
Union would like to assess what we are
doing to guide and to improve the
effectiveness of our collaboration to
work forward with sdg 10 especially
so having said that we enter into the
dialogue with the colleagues and Isabel
wiesler for the PPE is our first speaker
thank you so much for being with us and
for everything you said it's uh it's
important
I'm sorry
okay
I'm gonna continue in French
I just wanted to stress a couple of
points that you raised
and that is the focus on the Dignity of
every human being the freedom to be who
you are to believe or not to believe
these are integral parts of a person
which is sometimes overlooked
when I focus on this issue
I think we also have to
defend democracy authoritarian regimes
decide for people what they should be
what they should think
and that is dangerous for human dignity
I also think it's important that we be
aware that authentic authoritarian
regimes act beyond their own borders
their goal is also to destroy our
democracies
their influence is stronger
and they have means available to them
that are different to those available in
the past
propaganda and disinformation
have developed are used by
authoritarian regimes
and they are now a great threat to
democracy and therefore to human rights
I just wanted to highlight that
yes progress has been made you
mentioned that
but there is backsliding today
because of
the globalization of means of
communication
human rights are under threat as a
result so I just wanted to raise that
point I hope that we can dialogue in
these issues that you'll pick up this
point thank you for being with us and I
hope we see you again at the end of the
year for the anniversary of the
Declaration of Human Rights thank you
thank you very much so it's a time for
Libre committee representation from Epp
site also Carolyn brownsberger Reinhold
please the floor is yours for two
minutes
laughs
thank you very much for being here uh
sorry I wasn't prepared to talk but uh
the name registered so it's um great to
have you being here um you talked about
a lot of you had a lot of points and um
like you said we witnessed a throwback
and some of the human rights and woman
rights and lgbtqi rights and sometimes
I'm very concerned that we move
backwards more than forwards and I think
that we have to to fight these uh
rollbacks I'm sorry I don't have a
better word for this
um and that we have to fight this
extreme points
um whether one extreme poet and the
Other Extreme point because we had a lot
of um good um
yeah you walked a lot uh forwards in the
last um
centuries Century skin we can say
um and um I think we have to
um yeah maintain um this going forward
um
and
at the moment um we have this we have
this climate crisis we have
um this Wars all over our world um we
have this war in we can say in Europe
um but we say that um it affects us more
than we um
uh thought in uh in the first point
um so I hope that we can find a way to
work together again that we can move
forward again and that we fight this
extremism both um end of the extreme
points so thank you for being here to
talk with us it is very important we
don't have to forget
um to talk about it and to talk together
and find Solutions together so thank you
very much
thank you our next speaker is a
socialist and Democrats
thank you chair and uh thank you I
commissioner for your presentation and
having this opportunity for an exchange
of you I would like to raise three
concrete issues my first one is as you
know ngos and human rights activists
have been harshly criticizing the
so-called Libyan coast guard for years
for its human rights violations however
the EU supports them financially and
cooperates with them in March the United
Nations published a report stating that
the U supports and incites crimes
against humanity by funding the leaving
Coast Guard from your perspective what
should be the reaction of the EU to
these findings would you agree that the
EU should immediately stop cooperating
with an authority which is causing
murders rapes enslavement judicial
killings and false disappearances and do
you see similar dangerous developments
when the EU concludes agree agreements
like the reasons one with Tunisia my
second issue is
uh it refers to the right of
conscientious objection to military
service
especially in the context of the current
Russian war of aggression against
Ukraine we can see that many Russian but
also Ukrainian men do not want to
participate in the war which is against
international law but there are almost
no legal entry routes for them to seek
asylum in the EU however conscientious
objection is a human right what concrete
reactions should the youth take in order
to support conscientious objectives and
how can the EU and the UN cooperate in
that matter and my last issue
is the the fact that we must really
regret the non-extension of the Black
Sea grain agreement between Ukraine and
Russia
um I was I think this will have severe
impact on the food security it will be
in danger
and so
um
I would like to ask you could the UN do
more
to put it again on the political agenda
that we can proceed in this way and do
you think it would be a good idea that
the U.N Secretary General Mr guterres
himself
what visit Moscow Mr Putin together with
other representatives of success of the
important states of the global South to
achieve some progress in this regard
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Matthias nemetz also snd group but from
Libya committee
the floor is yours
thank you
thank you so much
um I'm here also is as a chairman of the
maghreb delegation as you know all the
five countries are quite well
involved also in our thoughts because of
the situation in the last period we are
more focused on the Tunisian
events and of course all the region is
facing tough times and the our position
is that we have to co-work with them uh
actually we are facing tough situation
in Libya in Algeria and the in Moroccan
sometimes we are we're adapting an ad
hoc resolution which are not having a
good impact in a in a bilateral
I mean in a bilateral relations
um so we have to take account
that we have many bodies in the European
Parliament you know
involving themselves in the in the
internal and bilateral issues so
sometimes this is also might it was my
proposal to the to the house of the
parliament we have to be a little bit
more aligned and not just the the
European Parliament bodies but even with
the All European institutions as you
know we are really critical regarding
the new events especially in Tunisia in
the in the approach of the European
commission regarding those issues there
are different views and we have many
many questions regarding the the
Tunisian issue
but you know we are here to defend of
course the values the values of the
human rights and you are more more than
welcome today
to being part of this debate so thank
you so much
thank you our next speaker is Charles
guerns from renew
thank you chairman in turn I'd like to
welcome Mr Turk amongst us I agree with
the points made um
I have the following points when it
comes to the issue of Human Rights
you'll only find people in favor in this
Parliament except for a few sad
exceptions the issue is implementing uh
human rights which is not the same thing
it gets more complicated
when it comes to persuading allies and
partners
or our opponents
that they should deliver on what is put
into very often the Preamble of trade
agreements and so on WE very often
insist on the following
classic scheme political representatives
in a country
uh let's say China negotiate economic
agreements and there's a press agreement
a press conference in which we're
declared to be partners but then a
little later on in the same place the
Foreign Affairs
ministers will be greeted with abuse in
the same country so it's as if there's a
division of labor between the two in the
same place but that doesn't work and
that's why
I would be in favor of a different
approach not an exclusive
one that rules out all the other
attempts that you are discussing but a
complementary approach
it's not for the first time
that in my rare appearances here I've
pleaded in favor of confidential
diplomacy I think we can progress on a
number of points more swiftly if we took
our inspiration from the benefits of
these policies
we don't want to interlock you to to
lose face from whom we want human rights
concessions they'll never do that in
front of a camera but they might do it
in a room where they are sheltered from
the public gaze
and now
without generalizing on these cases I
think we can make progress step by step
and step by step I think we can
achieve success and the major advantage
is that this is not
in the public eye the uyghurs
imprisoned or those saved from
the death penalty will not be given
visibility from such agreements
but that is vital
so I'd like to know
whether in your position
you are in a position to construct a
network of diplomats
who can get things going behind the
scenes in some way
Queens
thank you and I will for one speak in
German today
um
nice to see you here
and even nicer that we've had your
Institution for 75 years
I'm sometimes surprised by how many
people
in repressive regimes
are
helped out by the fact that uh
in their in their cases are brought up
in your reports and I think it's all the
more important uh for us
uh to see that
it might be religion or other reasons
that benefit from an institution
that uh shows that our common values and
common conventions are upheld and I
think it's never fully uh
achieved but I think it's uh excellent
that we've had this institution for 75
years now
against that background personally
I'm a in favor of universal periodic
reviews because I think it provides an
appropriate level way of
flagging up whether certain conventions
are abided by or whether there's a need
for improvement what I'm a little
troubled by and I can
certainly agree with previous speakers
is that we the European Union or the
member state
criticize other countries very strongly
but then go on to have political
relationships or agreements with those
countries and that criticism Falls by
the wayside this might be exemplified by
Tunisia for example where there's been a
lot of criticism on human rights but
then a billion uh Euro agreement was
signed and similar things apply to Egypt
the question is how do we try and plug
those loopholes and give the process
more credibility a couple of very
specific comments from me firstly the
Iran fact-finding Mission which
unfortunately is picking up pace and
carrying out its investigations
some individual regimes turned this down
there's a lot of pressure exerted when
there's cooperation
with a un missions
now we have to think about how we can
help people with temporary reception or
Asylum and so on do you feel that EU
member states are doing enough or
do you sometimes find yourself wishing
that our contribution is more strongly
held up by the institutions and it's not
simply a question of financial transfers
then human rights Defenders
and uh
when we Mark the anniversary in the
Autumn we need to think about how we
breathe life into this agreement to this
convention so it's not just on paper but
we really do
specifically help people protect people
how do we help these human rights
Defenders I don't think we do enough at
the moment now the protective feature
could be visas or Asylum
allowing them to networking conferences
uh
and so on sometimes they're forced into
exile for many years the Human Rights
Convention marking it 75 years is a
response to the Dreadful events of the
second World War I think political
Asylum is as well now even a
conservatives are questioning this in
Germany
and that shakes me to my core
uh human rights isn't just for the
Sunny Times it's also for when you're in
a real crisis and
when people are in a crisis when people
are attacked attacking it is uh
something that bothers me
you've talked about the pledging tree
you want to see
you've talked about that with respect to
to December I hope there's a strong
commitment on visas for human rights
Defenders when they need it and on
political Asylum
as a simple way of delivering our
commitments under the UN system and
protecting human rights that's something
that the European Union could do you use
double time but there is additional two
minutes for greens coordinator from
Libya committee Street Florissant
thank you thank you both cheers but
thanks a lot Mr Turk for uh for being
here and um giving us a chance to join
Julie celebrate the anniversary of the
human rights declaration uh and and I
have a question that combines actually
your previous and your current function
namely the human rights of refugees
because they are as you also said under
uh increasing pressure uh you you
mentioned briefly the Australian model
but I must say that the eu's tendency to
externalize and deter migrants and
refugees is going more and more into
that direction and I'm talking about
evidence-based policies which you
mentioned I'm very grateful for the
fact-finding mission report that the UN
came up with in March on the situation
of Libya where the U.N clearly stated
and concluded that the directorate for
combating irregular illegal migration
stability support apparatus but also the
Libyan Coast Guard are actively and
deeply be involved in crimes against
humanity including smuggling and
trafficking torture of slavery sexual
exploitation as also my colleague did
Marcus already mentioned but your
conclusion was also that the EU
contributes to these crimes against
humanity through its significant
financial support of the Libyan Coast
Guard and I must say I thought it would
be explosive news it would be a bump but
it was extremely silent afterwards there
was a human rights resolution afterwards
also adopted by the EU not mentioning
these devastating conclusions but only
asking to transfer the monitoring to the
Libyan authorities which is very cynical
of course and only mentioned some things
on technical assistance
so since then we really try to get
clarity how the EU reflects on this if
it's reviewing its policy if anything
has happened since then and I must say
I'm going against walls in the EU so I
really would like to know from you more
on one side what are you doing now as a
follow-up to that report and the lack of
response from the EU but what strategies
would you see as allies in human rights
that we could jointly do in order to uh
to increase the attention and change
policies wouldn't you think that funding
at least should be made conditional or
fundamental rights compliance and that a
monitoring system would need to be
established which is transparent and
independent
and that brings me to my last question
because uh un clearly urged for
continuing its monitoring mission in
Libya what is the state of play of that
is there a need for more funding because
I understand the Mandate has not been
prolonged and what could we do in order
to make sure that you can keep on your
important work there thank you
spoke about the silence uh in the
reaction to the U.N reports our
committees have not been silent
but silence comes also as a result of
the fact that the respective
commissioner do not react to the
invitation of our committees which will
not lead to the fact that we will become
silent quite the opposite we will become
louder and louder next speaker is
big Wallace for the left group and
afterwards we take the freedom to go
back to forget work because he has
already taken notes and notes and notes
and we then open for a second round if
that is okay
you are okay then we continue with
without a break and all the colleagues
who have raised their hand will speak
but now it's me
thanks very much chair and thanks very
much for your presentation uh you made
the point that the Ukraine war and the
climate crisis are two of the main
drivers of food crisis
but the United Nations report which is
published only last week the state of
food security and nutrition in the world
in 2023 uh the report actually makes the
Pines uh that the war in Ukraine has
driven 23 million people into hunger a
number that pales in comparison to the
other drivers of hunger such as the
impact of commercialized food markets
Financial speculators it says now
dominate The Food Market holding over 60
percent of some markets compared to 12
15 years ago
and the report goes on to say well there
are indeed food shortages the current
food crisis is a price crisis rather
than a supply crisis the leading cause
as even the European economic and social
committee agrees is financial
speculation in Food Markets now my
second Point uh
on the Black Sea grain initiative
the Russians have been claiming that the
UN and turkey have failed to fulfill
parts of the agreement that would have
allowed the easy export of Russian grain
and agricultural products which have
been affected due to the Sciences
imposed by the US and EU uh I just
wonder what do you think of that and it
there's there's uh there's also reports
that according to un data Graham from
Ukraine has been supplied to 45
countries uh since the deal was formed
but only 12 percent of it went to Africa
and 40 percent of it went to the rich
countries of Europe I would like for
your comment on that and my last Point
uh I I noticed that Kenneth Ross uh
reckons you were the wrong man for the
job so I kind of figured to myself but
you must be there must be something good
about you because if uh I think if he
thinks you're the wrong man you probably
are the right fella and I was glad to
see that you're prepared to focus uh on
the the the social end of Human Rights
about the right to health housing and
whatever because we drifted away from
that a bit and kind of rods seems to
have a problem with that but uh I I
commend you for that approach thank you
thank you andreos cubillos
well uh thanks a lot chairman since I am
not a member either of uh or Libra so
appreciate very much for possibility to
participate and to ask the question
especially that I wrote a small letter
you know
on very specific and very important
report from High Commissioner of human
rights to the committee asking to have
special discussion on that and this is
uh Mr High Commissioner really I praise
your your report which you published
earlier in in March perhaps this year uh
which is called situational human rights
in Belarus in the run-up to the 2020
presidential elections and in its
aftermath I simply want to quote you
know several several statements because
this is the first time at least one I
hear in this region you know in Belarus
and Russia when such on such a level as
high Commission on human rights now
report speaks very clearly about abuses
against the opposition against Civil
Society we know we know the facts we
were witnessing all of us you know but
with a very clear legal language that
some of us also know crimes are coming
up to the crime against humanity which
means that you know Zan International
Justice you have a possibility and
responsibility to react including with
the tribunal so my question is you know
by commissioner how you foresee what
what should be done next including by
you know political community of of
European Union by by legal communities
you know and so on and so on because
really it's not enough just to react
with our statements of concern and so on
about what is happening in Belarus Sumo
and and what what the regime is doing
and and and and we know very well you
know uh
hundreds and thousands of people are
suffering in the prisons some of them
are dying recently again one one of the
no very well-known leaders artists you
know died in the prison and that is
really where I see the way with your job
with your report to move forward my
second part of the question very short
can you imagine that similar report
could be done on human rights violation
against opposition people and several
you know Society people in Russia
but you know we do not have proper legal
instruments to move against the regime
in when they are violating human rights
domestically we know what to do with a
crime against you know a crime of
organization against Ukraine but how to
stop you know the war against its own
Nation that's what Louis CSS really
British
thank you very much the High
Commissioner has a huge and impressing
capacity to take notes so we continue
and our next speaker is Carlos cerino
snd
thank you very much I use my mother
language so I invite you to use that
interpretation devices
I don't know if the commissioner
understands Portuguese if it to speak
with the Secretary General could be
useful
thank you very much
[Music]
commissioner welcome to European
Parliament
as the EP Rapport Turf for the
humanitarian situation I would like to
concentrate on the situation of Human
Rights so there's a humanitarian crisis
globally
the number of those needing help is
constantly on the rise resources are
becoming ever more scant
in your recently
tabled
in in its most recent report the
parliament calls for a humanitarian
strategy that is commensurate with the
task and it's important that ecosystems
for humanitarian
Aid is created the situation on the
ground needs to be better known it's
important that the players are providing
humanitarian assistance know the needs
and can integrate properly the current
resources are not enough they need to be
more efficient we need to reach out to
more people we need to solve situations
better the United Nations
is the prime mover in humanitarian
assistance and is a key actor in
ensuring that we can get a grip on the
current challenges I said that we need
to think globally and uh in fact and act
locally and so I'd like to ask the
following question
how do you regard the role of the UN
agencies
in coordinating this ecosystem that will
need to be more resilient on the ground
should the
local agencies and actors not be
strengthened what are you planning to do
to strengthen that to ensure that we can
act
globally and be resilient locally thank
you
Obrigado our next colleague is Jordy
Kanas for renew
thank you very much chairman
I'd like to thank you for giving me the
opportunity to take the floor at today's
meeting
as the High Commissioner was saying
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
has never been more called into doubt
than this time based on the principles
not on its enforcement
and there are serious threats not just
in the implementation of these rights
but
perhaps now there is a significant
threat to the principles to these
Universal values in the Declaration
people are calling into question
um the universal nature of these rights
and
and this is perhaps so the Declaration
is more under threat than ever
now
I perhaps like to focus on a more
specific localized matter
from my analysis of electoral processes
on electron observation missions for
example we have seen in recent years
deterioration in countries with a formal
democracies on fundamental basic rights
based on r2o 21 participation in
democracy for example
and there's persecution of journalists
attacks on human rights Defenders
Environmental environmentalists
but
often
there are formal mechanisms
against being voted and are being
elected and on voting
now this phenomenon is increasing in
certain areas of the world in Latin
America for example
where these
tools legal tools are being used to
attack fundamental rights that are
recognized in the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights but also civil and
political rights
and when we have such specific
situations that are so obvious I haven't
seen
a positioning of the United Nations
and the human rights unhcr
and I really thought you have when I was
listening to the colleagues I thought
you have a mammoth task
you look at all of the situations around
the world with threats violations of
human race it really is infinite
and
it's very difficult to find a solution
to such a complex situations but there
are some things that are in our hands
and there are things that we can perhaps
do
and
this is where I think that your work is
particularly relevant
now
I think that
it's important
for the High Commissioner and your
office to be closer to these processes
because I think that we can avoid them
happening prevent them happening thank
you
next week is Vice President of European
Parliament
um
I saw that the delightfully the Human
Rights Council had a debate on the
deplorable situation of Myanmar which
has suffered a incredible human rights
consequences and repression of of the
People by the military for already
two and a half years is it
and um I would like to ask you what your
sort of key observations for what the
International Community could do to to
to to to stop this military coup and
support the Democratic forces which also
is defense of Human Rights
you also paid attention to the situation
of the 1 million rohingya refugees you
reminded us that it is the largest
refugee camp
uh in the world with one million uh
people uh in Bangladesh and by the way
I'm aware that the EU special
representative of Human Rights Eamon
Gilmore is supposed to be there right
now uh this week to to to acquaint
himself with the situation
um
a second point I'd like to make that um
I I thank you for your your notion of
Human Rights economy I think it's very
important that we understand that there
will be no solutions to the global
challenges we face
with such huge in inequalities the
climate crisis Etc unless the solutions
are human rights based and I know that
you have paid quite a lot of attention
to to the sort of business and human
rights track of the UN and the solutions
and you're very well aware I believe
that in the EU at the moment we are
legislating on those issues so perhaps
you could say a couple of words about
how you see the importance of this
business and human rights framework
and is there a chance to to come to some
sort of global standard on this uh there
is an intergovernmental working group in
Geneva and and we are just starting as a
drug committee to start a report on how
the EU could relate to this process
which it has kept its distance to so far
thank you
thank you Heidi our next speaker is
David David Liga PPE
thank you so much hi commissioner for
having this exchange of views with us
today I would like to hear your views on
the Iranian regime and the Crackdown of
the ongoing Revolution and peaceful
protests of the women of Iran I mean
today we see increased Violence by rgc
and the morality police and also even
more enforcement again to where the
hijab
so just for your information I just
asked today my colleagues for their
support in my nomination today for
masamini and the women of Iran for the
sucker of price I hope for my colleague
support in in that one but my question
is also about the human U.N Human Rights
Council
appointed Iran to chair the 2023 social
Forum which is for me completely
yeah incredible uh horrible uh Iran I
mean we're talking about a country that
executes their own people simply for
criticizing religion on on social media
and uh we sent a letter together I sent
the letter together with 30 of my
colleagues uh criticizing this to Russia
balik
um we didn't get any response for that
but how is this affecting your work that
you and hrcr is legitimizing the Iranian
regime at the same time as your mission
is to scrutinize HR abuses
thank you
thanks David this very important
question
looker snd
film Guru I'm also going to speak in
German and
thank you
let me try and simplify things
so let's split between the west and the
South
particularly since the 24th of February
last year where
um
the geopolitical plates are shifting
the EU is looking for new Partnerships
now you said that human rights shouldn't
become an Annex
I think you're preaching to the
converted here of course but if I look
outside this house
then in reality there are a lot of
countries that are a long way from being
sound democracies
and we'll then have more partners for
economic support and who are ready to
LEAP into the breach
and where this narrative might appear
we always hear from people where the
Europeans always turn up with this Annex
and that might be a problem and they can
get support from someone else without
the annex now of course I've simplified
the picture
but we want Partnerships which we can
drive forward
I mean we have to factor in the fact
that these countries have different
histories different cultures their young
countries
that all has to be
taken into account
so that we can take a decision on how we
build up the partnership
without undermining our deep-seated uh
support for human rights and media
freedom
so
how do you see this
um Middle Road that we have to
go down that splitter between the two
points thank you so leave for the queens
please
thank you very much chairman uh we are
higher commissioner I would like to
bring into our discussion uh the issue
of
minority rights the rights of minorities
including the rights of national
minorities ethnic minorities indigenous
peoples
are still being called into question
across across the world
some national minorities are victims of
human rights violation violations many
intra Interstate conflicts unfold mainly
because of discrimination and human
rights violation violations against
specific groups
minority groups and some of these
conflicts have led another state leading
to terrible atrocities so my my question
is how are you how is your office
approaching the protection of minorities
being them National ethnic or indigenous
peoples thank you
on procedures I will now give the floor
to Leopoldo Lopez still for the PPE then
we have a colleague munir Satori online
and then I asked Christina
address us from the external Action
Service and forca can take the time to
reconcentrate
all the
magnific contributions from from our
side Leopoldo
thank you
and thank you I commissioner for coming
definitely it's a good cause to
celebrate the signing of uh
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
I was impressed by your
Shakespearean introduction on the
decision to act or not to act on human
rights
yes definitely some of the world decided
to act and we signed
but I I would
ask you does acting
necessarily have another question how to
act
and there I seem to find
great contradictions
so far we have
at least to my uh understanding only two
ways to act
either through sanctions
or
through creation
of criminal courts international
criminal reports which by the way not
all the
signatures that we have in the Universal
rights are on the same
paper with the criminal courts as you
well know
my question is very simple
in your view
which is a better way a practical way
to right the wrongs of the world
in human rights violations
because we seem
at least and we have a very unfortunate
sample of the European Union
that if we sanction
countries
or people
in the Union
some of the member states do not respect
that
and they do the just people who are
Ascension go freely on territories of
the Union
the same thing happens in the United
Nations and I imagine
so
is there a way of being practical to
impose and right the wrongs thank you
thank you and now Leopoldo now we asked
munir Satori
is connected with us
foreign
first of all thank you hi commissioner
for being with us
the word that you do is absolutely
crucial
where human rights
are being abused more and more
the special procedures and the treaties
are still very important my first
question is migration
the member states of the EU are refusing
to ratify the UN convention on migrants
rights the UN has published a report
suggesting that EU financing is
complicit in crimes committed by the
Libyan Coast Guard
what do you think of the recent
agreement between
the EU and Tunisia
where the dealing the treating with
migrants is essentially outsources and
do you think this is going to have a
negative impact on the right of migrants
I'd also like to ask you about your
report on businesses and migration
trade and human rights lines are moving
in Europe we hope there'll be a
regulation on this but the eu's been
rather passive when it comes to uh
negotiations on the latest un instrument
that legally binding instrument on human
rights uh between Enterprises and and
migrant so we're going to be discussing
this in our committee but I wonder what
you feel of the eu's point of view on
this crucial instrument and the
negotiations on it how we're going to
make sure that all countries including
in the north constructively engage with
this process
I've supported the
families that have tried to get French
children from back from prison camps in
Syria the UN has condemned France's
attitude there are a hundred children
concerned I wonder if you could give us
your view on that particular situation
as well thank you
and now we give the floor to Christina
kokinakis she is the Deputy managing
director on values and multilateral
relations in the external Action Service
please Christina
thank you very much Mr chair
um well welcome also to uh to the other
chair of the other committee and of
course to the U.N High Commissioner uh
from the side of also of the external
Action Service uh it's a privilege to
have you here
today
um it's a first exchange uh the European
Parliament has with you and um and from
the side of the external Action Service
where we prepared your visit during the
last uh weeks uh and the months together
with my own team we are very happy to uh
to have you here and we feel privileged
to have this Exchange
um I will try to to
um to put
um forward a couple of points uh also in
the relation especially in the relation
to udhr 75 to this year where uh at
least two big human rights anniversaries
coincide
udhr but also 30 years of the vdpa of
the Vienna declaration program of action
the letter
um those who are
younger than at least I might maybe not
remember was a time where there was no
Office of the United Nations High
Commissioner for us for the
International Community and the vtpa
established the office so this is why
it's it's a relevant um milestone for us
um so concentrating on this year of um I
would call A year of opportunities
um rather than of challenges uh of
course being aware of all the challenges
we are facing uh the pushback when it
comes to
um universality indivisibility and
interdependence of Human Rights we are
fully committed to push back on the
pushback together with the U.N High
Commissioner we are working I would
really say in tandem since the EU is one
of the Strategic partners of the office
both politically but also financially
and we are trying we were trying and
have been trying to um Ally also our
common Endeavors to commemorate these
anniversaries and to use them as a tool
to push back on the pushback
on human rights
um the EU um I I mentioned one of the
Strategic partners of the office of the
High Commissioner
um also in the sense of uh reaffirming
um the independence of your office which
is uh which becomes more and more
relevant
um we are working together with you to
um
to try to um
find and build alliances concentrate we
confirm alliances on on our work for
universality of Human Rights this is not
an easy thing to do but um I think we
reflect it well during the past years I
would say even how we can do that
as to the how
um we will
um
try to reach out to new constituencies
so one thing is to continue to build
these Partnerships we have with civil
society with uh with you with these
institutions we have but also to reach
out to new constituencies and their
youth is obviously one of the important
pillars we have it was a very good I
have to say event the High Commissioner
hosted yesterday evening here in
Brussels in the in the um
the Brazil where
we we included youth
um we are pushing on this a lot from the
side of the external Action Service also
when it comes to strategic communication
where we've been working uh for over a
year now with youth influences
um and we reached over 75 million of
people engaging with us on this path to
to reach out uh and to push for uh for
universality uh let me let me also
mention
um of course we are we are we are very
much concerned about the war in Ukraine
we see this um as a um as a violation of
the U.N Charter
by one of the p5s it is a violation
that's of international law but also of
international humanitarian law and in
this context but not only in this
context we focus our work a lot on
accountability and the fight against
impunity
um as um two more points uh to mention
um we we've been concentrating so as uh
to reach out to new partners and
alliances much more in economic social
and cultural rights during the past one
and a half two years than we did before
uh we want to do this in this context of
this indivisibility of Human Rights we
are aware that we can not only do civil
and political we we need to push also on
the economic social and cultural rights
and let me add that also in the context
of the last Human Rights Council session
the 53 third where we saw some Partners
such as the OIC uh
um pushing back on on a very good
cooperation we had
um we are aware that we need to link
these two parts of of the human rights
um so maybe on on an optimistic point a
year of opportunities a year where we
hope that by the end of the year
together with an input also from the UI
in the center European Parliament is
planning something we will also plan a
conference later this year we we will be
able to give you some input hi
commissioner and to uh to give you
pledges
um how to reconfirm what we have on the
table namely Juliet are reconfirmed by
the ptpa
thank you Christina thanks anje our
co-chair and let me say before I give
the floor to Volker Turk High
Commissioner
this is the last working day for most of
the colleagues here in Brussels uh there
is a public holiday tomorrow and and
plus also the European Parliament is
closed colleagues will travel on
missions next week but most probably
more or less not come back to Brussels
that so many colleagues are here
from different political backgrounds
from different committees is a
compliment for you and for your work and
underscores the importance of our
collaboration you have seen that
colleagues raised and reflected the
reports that were presented by the
United Nations which are of the essence
for our political uh work here please
you have the floor but let me also say
because the one or the other is perhaps
already thinking when to leave this room
I wish you all a very best vacation time
uh also in the name of of Andrea will
say get some fresh energy and that was
like a terrorist because they are so
great people and my team because they
are also so great people would like to
invite the guests as well as the
colleagues from the various committees
to raise a class outside of the room so
there is an incentive to wait until the
very end
don't want to be an obstacle between
um that and and the class plus plus was
much deserved holidays look a couple of
quick reactions to what you have
mentioned
[Music]
first of all I'm very much in line with
you about
defending Democratic and Civic spaces
Civic space in the broad sense of the
word
human rights are a response to that
article 20 of the International Bank on
civil and political rights
includes in paragraph two
restrictions about hate speech
and incitement to violence
I think
that there has to be used where
disinformation is to be seen
and where
the discourse that polarizes is used
or where there are attempts to
destroy the foundations of our democracy
and societies I mean it's not underpins
our social contract we have to think
about how we find those things that
bring us together rather than those
areas where there are division because
division doesn't help
particularly when you look at the
challenges that we're faced with he did
Issue this report uh last year I think
it was in November we have made a number
of very important recommendations if I
were to look from a broader perspective
I think it is very important
Whenever there is anyone doing any
support to security law enforcement type
agencies
to apply human rights due diligence
policy when it comes to that I mean
that's for me that we have it by the way
in the U.N it took us a long time to
develop a human rights due diligence
policy in our own support that the
United Nations gives in peace operations
special political missions to the
security sector
because we know how sensitive this is
especially in the type of countries
where we work
I mean not just Libya I mean many many
other countries as well so I would
encourage real thought to be given when
it comes to support for security sector
in whatever way outside the EU
that you may want to think about the
human rights due diligence policy I mean
I think there are some of it that exists
but I think there could be much broader
thinking about precisely that issue
um on the conscientious objection to
military service it is part of the human
rights framework there are for instance
a committee on the on on economic on
civil and political rights has
pronounced itself we can try to find
references to it
in the Asylum context
um someone especially as you mentioned
if there has been a flagrant violation
of the U.N Charter and if someone does
not want to participate a military
action against it there is a claim to
Asylum
because it would then become political
persecution on account of a political
opinion or membership of a particular
social group and there is if you like
some quite well established
jurisprudence on this
Black Sea crane initiative I can assure
you one thing because I've seen it or
when I was still with the Secretary
General in New York
I mean the Secretary General has
I think not one single Stone left
unturned in order to get this deal last
year
and I'm sure over the last couple of
months he has done exactly the same
there are two of my colleagues Rebecca
Greenspan and Martin Griffiths who also
work hard on this I just hope that this
is a temporary setback
and that the Black Sea crane initiative
will still come together because the
world needs it and by the way we have
quite a lot of statistics on where and I
I don't have them with me but I'm very
happy to share it with you because I saw
there was a similar question raised to
our spokesperson in New York
about where the crane goes it's it's I
mean there is some that did go to High
income countries that is correct but
there was then follow up from that and
you know for the UN for us it was
important to get the fertilizers out and
to get the wheat out and the grain out
because of the impact that we see and we
have done quite a lot of analysis
precisely on that point but I don't have
it with me at the moment but it's it's
it's an important but frankly the Black
Sea crane initiative is one that is
extremely important to have revitalized
as quickly as possible because it will
have massive impact if we if we don't
get it done
on diplomacy Secret
um I mean it's actually you know if I
look at my own mandate if I look at the
Mandate that was given to me 30 Years
Ago by the general assembly by all 193
member states
it's it's there are lots of tensions
within that mandate because on the one
hand it very clearly talks about putting
the spotlight on emerging human rights
situations making sure that we promote
and fulfill the the promises of of the
human rights mechanisms
but it also says that I have a
responsibility to engage in constructive
dialogue with member states about the
protection and promotion of Human Rights
I can tell you in the last couple of
months
I can and this is the nature of it of
course there is a lot of work that is
done behind the scenes
and that has that can only be done
behind the scenes especially when it
comes to people who are arbitrarily
detained or political prisoners
and I have usually a list
of people in my pocket whenever I see a
leader of a country where indeed this
happens
and I can tell you without mentioning
these countries that in a number of
situations it had actually led to
releases of political prisoners and
that's part of
our work it's part of our tools it's
it's something that is incredibly
important what I've also seen this is I
think a more general question because of
the polarization the divisions and the
geopolitics that we see today there have
been many countries
ever since I started to have reached out
and it is especially countries who are
caught up in the middle and in the
geopolitical tensions that we have and
they want to seek a strong relationship
even if they know that their own systems
are not perfect there are a lot of
issues to be dealing with but as always
nothing is always it's not black and
white
none of the situations are black and
white and we really need to see very
carefully where are things that can
happen and can happen in the right
direction where are things that
absolutely are unacceptable and we need
to say so but where are things also
where we can negotiate with them
and the the interesting thing is because
of the tensions
countries do want this strong link with
United Nations they want the link to the
Charter they want the link to the
fundamental values and especially the
ones
who want to embark on a reform process
within their own countries they they
want to see human rights as part of it
and one of the big challenges is
precisely to push back against the
notion that this is about Western values
or european values it is about Universal
values and that's the big message that I
have because if we compartmentalize
if we say it's about African values or
it's about U.S values we are going to
lose a big battle and it's also not
historically correct
it is about fundamental
human values human rights and the Vienna
conference was incredibly important
because it actually put an end to
cultural relativism it put an end
to this thing that you know the universe
Declaration was crafted at the time when
all the countries that are now members
of the United States were still colonies
well actually
in Vienna it was in 93
it was after the decolonization process
it was after the apartheid regime in
South Africa fell it was after the end
of the Cold War
and it was two years of negotiations to
achieve the Declaration and the program
of action
and reconfirming revalidating
revitalizing the universal nature of the
human rights regime and that is so
important and we need to latch on to
this and not to have you know all kinds
of dialogue and narratives
that actually
throw dust in our eyes
and make us very foggy well no it there
are documents that were painstakingly
negotiated that we need to come back to
and come back to and come back to and
use in whatever we can
and it goes a bit also to the discussion
the UPR is incred incredibly important
it has to be peer-reviewed it has to be
with a sense of humility I mean
sometimes I also find within the human
rights community
let's be humble
we all each and every one of us but also
if you look at the history of our of our
countries including in Europe we went
through hell
let's not forget what happened in the
last century
sometimes it takes some of the things
that we take for granted today were not
taken for granted even 20 years ago if I
think of gender equality or or LGBT IQ
Plus
we now think that it has to happen
overnight everywhere
sometimes we have to approach it with a
sense of understanding and humility that
achieves exactly what we want to achieve
and has the impact that we want to have
but maybe uses different methods to
achieve exactly what we want to achieve
but we have to be careful about it
because I often sense if I may be very
honest and Frank with you some arrogance
and we need to be wary about it because
it's not gonna open up the dialogue and
the transformation that we need
um on
I mean you also mentioned the Iran the
effect finding Mission I mean and and
the Iran more generally as you know I've
been extremely outspoken about the
situation in Iran we the funding mission
is now in place they will do their first
report in in September
um we need to be very careful about
reprisals against human rights Defenders
I think some of the methods that I was
we also discussed yesterday uh for human
rights Defenders are very very important
whatever we can do to strengthen them is
going to be critical because human
rights Defenders are at the Forefront
whenever I go on an official country
visit and I visited certain countries
ever since I started I make a special
point to meet human rights to vendors to
meet victims to meet Civil Society
organizations before I meet the
government
it works in most country situation not
always but it's really important to do
that because it gives us a very
different
I mean it makes you feel what's
happening in a country in a very
different way before you engage with
government officials and and that's also
very very key
um so I hope that that support that we
get can be increased strengthened in
whatever way because we will absolutely
need it and let's not forget article 14
is the right to seek and enjoy Asylum
from persecution
was very deliberately chosen as a result
of not least what happened during the
second world war and the right to
political Asylum
a Cornerstone of the human rights
framework
um FM I mean the effect founding mission
on Libya that you mentioned I was very
disappointed about
the fact and I'd be very open about it
that the Human Rights Council doesn't
consider it anymore which doesn't mean
that there is an obligation on me to do
it
and I've I mean there are the
recommendations we have of course the
presence in Libya itself
for us it's critical that we do the
continue to do the monitoring the
reporting and the documenting
and that we you know as I said
that the monitoring is also done in such
a way that everyone knows what is
happening in the country and and and
follow up on the on the recommendation
so the onus is probably now more on me
than what the council does but I
absolutely agree we need we cannot we
cannot we need to be on it because I
agree I mean what I have seen myself in
my previous life in unhcr when I see how
migrants and refugees and Asylum Seekers
get treated
by the Libyan authorities it's
horrendous
there's no other word for that on food I
mean the
there is actually a food security Summit
I think it's this week in in Rome that
looks precisely at the different aspects
of it including also the role of the
private sector in all of this and the
business interests and
and it's it's precisely for that reason
that
from a human rights perspective the
right to food
is absolutely critical to analyze it so
that we see who benefits from Price
rises from from from the from the
increases in prices what is it that we
can do and which brings me again back to
this human rights economy that is
critical and the biggest ask
and the biggest problem in terms of
tensions that we also see is precisely
related to the International Financial
system that we have because it is unfair
it's no longer equitable
it doesn't deal anymore with the
delivery especially on austerity
measures if you do a human rights impact
analysis of austerity measures you would
probably look at them very differently
in the future
and it is really important that we we
look at economic systems including
fiscal policies and budget analysis from
a human rights perspective we have done
we have invested a lot more in this
including with economists
because we also want to provide that
type of analysis back to the UN system
and to member states
what next on Belarus
um the fact that I said
what we said about that some of what is
happening May amount to crimes against
humanity is a very strong signal to
whoever
would and you know the fact that we
document what is happening is an
important signal to prosecution around
the world of precisely looking at this
in much more detail on on Russia
by the way we have about 14 commissions
of inquiry and fact training missions
that work on an accountability
mechanisms around the world it's the
highest number we have ever had I also
hope that we can get more support on
having a stronger capacity within my
office to be able to to deliver on the
accountability mechanisms very fast uh
you know there is on the Russian
Federation the last Council decided to
appoint a special operator on the human
rights situation in in the Russian
Federation and we will hear from her I
think at the September meeting and this
is important mandate on humanitarian and
the humanitarian needs
I mean it is clear
that the humanitarian needs outpace
what is able to deliver on the budget
side but I also want to see a much
stronger linkage to the human rights
pillar of the United Nations because if
we invest more in some of the
preventative work that we are doing
and it doesn't cost all that much money
I mean I can tell you one particular
country situation that I have in mind
three million country presence we got
300 people out of detention we had
access to all detention centers in the
country we could
engage in legal reform in that country
it definitely helped
to decrease the repression that we saw
if we didn't have it
we would probably spend billions in
humanitarian needs and somehow and I
think it goes back to this point how can
we show that prevention actually works
which is very difficult to prove
but for me if we if we don't only want
to pay lip service to the human rights
pillar we also need to find adequate
funding for it and I can tell you and
I've said it publicly many times I do
think that if I look at all the things
and the incredible potential that we
have in the human rights framework
we probably need at least a doubling of
the budget
and I'm making also the case to you I
think whatever support we can get from
you on that front I would be very very
grateful
the universality of the regime as a I
think I I mentioned this before
and on the on Myanmar
Bangladesh
is incredibly important you saw the cuts
in the food rations already that's
problem
but also when it comes to Myanmar to
to Myanmar as well
we need to think about the day after
because we know that repression is not
gonna work we need to look at who
supports the attachment or where does
the money go
and we need to find ways and means
to
have a bit of a strategy around
precisely those issues of of what can be
done
once the day after occurs and I think we
need to prepare for it now
um well business and human rights there
is a declaration on business and human
rights that is very important that was
adopted by the general assembly
it's good good to go back to that there
is this intergovernmental process of a
working group on business and human
rights again important to to bear in
mind on the social Forum look I
understand there was only one country
it was Iran that put itself forward it's
obviously not something that that is
really member states but it's nothing
that where I can even influence it it's
it's how it is I think you wrote already
to the to the president of the council
um and it's yeah I mean sometimes I wish
that member states would look at these
things very carefully in the future
um yeah I think
that is probably let me just see whether
there was well on sanctions just to
mention sanctions I mean there's a lot
one can say about the tools that we have
and we shouldn't only look at
I mean we have a whole human rights
Machinery let's not forget about this we
have the UPR we have the human rights
mechanisms we have the treaty bodies and
they are very helpful in advancing the
human rights called sanctions
I often see it when it comes to sectoral
sanctions that they have an impact on
the human rights of people and we need
to be very careful about that we need
always humanitarian exemptions to it
because if we don't have them it will
affect people in a very different way
and we also need to make sure that they
are applied in such a way that they
don't affect the human rights of
people around the world and on migration
alcohol I fully agree with with our
colleague when it comes to the return of
Third Country Nationals out of North
North Syria
um this is let's also not forget an
obligation to take them back
but also for us when it comes to
migration and Refugee policies the offer
is obviously working very closely with
unhcr is to provide independent
monitoring at the most sensitive areas
where these where these potential
violations could occur and that's
important for us because it provides
feedback to all of you as well on how
everyone is faring when it comes to the
respect for human rights of migrants and
of refugees
so again thank you very much I know this
specific law thank you very much I
commissioned them
[Applause]
thank you
on behalf of my co-chair and myself I
would also like to thank the
interpreters that had given us overtime
and I wish also to the interpreters and
really good refreshing summer break so
that we see you back after the summer
break here in your extremely useful
support
folk attack you have addressed the rich
debate that we had during the last hours
here in the room and it was a
qualitative very very high discussion
and we thank you for your responses but
also for your Frank language because the
openness of our exchange is decisive for
making Brokers together our 12 committee
will try and fully hearted insist on
mainstreaming human rights in all our
legislative files especially on the
external Affairs activities the trade
agreements the legislative files that
are still open and we will do our
foreseen missions to the Ukraine to
Ethiopia into Lebanon in the second half
of our year 23